était ce week-end deux élections
régionales en allemagne en saxe et dans
le brandebourg qui se situent toutes les
deux dans l'ex rda l'ex allemagne de
l'est et les résultats témoignent d'une
certaine nostalgie au fond des allemands
de l'est avec une poussée des néo
communistes et surtout une très forte
poussée de l'extrême droite jérôme
bonnet
rentrée mouvementée hier soir de holger
apfel au parlement de dresde ayant
multiplié l'électorat du npd par sept
pour atteindre 9 2% des voix il y
siègera avec onze autres députés du
parti d'extrême droite visiblement ça ne
fait guère
vous donner un coup de pied à la volonté
des électeurs vous pouvez crier
s'exclame-t-il
les nazis dehors rétorque que
l'assistance
en extérieur les policiers ont bien du
mal à contenir d'autres manifestants
anti-nazis
à la télévision au moment où apple prend
la parole pour dire que c'est un grand
jour pour les allemands qui veulent
rester allemand tous les représentants
les autres partis quitte le plateau
l'émission doit être interrompue
démocrate depuis plusieurs années le
gouvernement essaie de faire interdire
le npd provoquant les manifestations de
quelques centaines de néonazis encadrés
par une police presque aussi nombreuses
mais l'année dernière la cour
constitutionnelle a annulé
l'interdiction du npd pour vice de forme
ce matin à berlin la presse a pris le
parti de la discrétion sur cette percée
de l'extrême droite en saxe les journaux
préfère faire leur une sur matthias
platzeck un proche du chancelier
schröder qui a réussi à sauver les
meubles dans les autres élections
régionales au brandebourg où il est
pourtant talonné par les néo communistes
qui voudraient bien gouverner avec lui